43 people were shot last weekend in
chicago
three fatally continuing a long-standing
crime trend
in a city that has been continuously and
exclusively run by democrats since 1931.
the current mayor has not done anything
about it even as shootings have spiked
50 percent
over the past year 5-0 but now
the current democrat mayor insists she
has finally
identified the problem what is it take a
guess
what do you think is the problem
corruption no
no lawlessness not a chance
bad education nope do you know what the
problem is
it's it's the answer to every one of
these social issues
racism racism
is specifically anti-black racism by the
way because that according to the left
is the only
real racism that there is there's no
such thing as anti-white racism
anti-black racism is the cause of all
the problems in chicago
so says chicago mayor lori lightfoot who
declared on thursday
that the systemic racism
in chicago is a quote public health
crisis the city needs to divert 10
million dollars in grants from the cdc
grants that were meant to fight
coronavirus to establish quote healthy
chicago equity zones quote
at almost every point in our city's
history sadly racism
has taken a devastating toll on the
public health and well-being of our
residents of color and particularly
those who are black
chicago has a lot of problems
over the past year during coronavirus
during the lockdowns i should say
shootings and murders are up 50 percent
50 5-0 racism right it's all
white racists going out and hunting down
poor innocent black men it's all
trump supporting white men in maga hats
yelling it's magga country on the south
side of chicago
while poor old jesse smilet just tries
to eat his subway salad
right is that what it is well it is a
lot like that in that those
two alleged white trump supporters were
giant nigerian guys who were hired by
smallett himself
if you look at the crime statistics in
chicago
what percentage of the victims are black
75
okay that's pretty bad 75 of the victims
are black
so what 75 of the perpetrators are white
no
turns out when you look at the killers
71.3 percent
are black so almost say a little bit
less
so do white people make up the rest of
that no of the victims 18.9
are hispanic of the killers 24.6 percent
are hispanic so that's that's
interesting that's kind of making up for
the other numbers
and then how about white people of the
victims 4.6
or white of the killers 3.5 percent
are white so significantly less likely
to be a killer than to be killed if you
were white in chicago
a racism has nothing to do with it
unless
all of these black murderers are
anti-black racists these hispanic
murderers are anti-hispanic racists
probably not
racism is as we've said before on this
show just a stand-in
for very shallow thinking progressives
for secularists
to be able to make sense of the fact of
sin we know that sin
pervades the world we know original sin
is not some
untested theory it is just an observable
fact
we are broken we all fall short of the
glory of god we all do
bad stuff and because we all do bad
stuff there's a lot of bad stuff
in the world but we can't make sense of
that anymore so the only
evil that we can ever talk about is
racism
even though there's just no it's insane
it's insane to say
that chicago's problems are because of
racism
that 72 percent of killer 71.3 percent
of killers in chicago
are black because of what because of
secret
self-hating racism doesn't make sense
it's not just chicago
what this is leading to is a very
perverse
system of injustice whereby the
imaginary problem of systemic racism the
completely made-up
contrived problem of systemic racism
don't forget the only legal racism in
this country is against whites and
asians
in university admissions it's called
affirmative action there are other
things that come out of that other sort
of grants and other
legal issues but it all goes in that
direction
it does not go in the other direction
but because we have this bizarre
distortion of reality this misperception
we have
even greater injustice hey i'm so glad
that you liked
that video there's a whole show there's
an entire episode out there that you can
get what's the title
knives at a gunfight head on over you
can check it out on youtube
on the apple podcasts app on spotify on
stitcher on google play and you can
pre-order my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds ring
the bell subscribe we'll see you next
[Music]
time